as always we'll be prepared
the NYPD and our entire Public Safety
apparatus are always prepared
we are working closely with all of our
partners to ensure everyone's safety
tomorrow
and we are asking for the Public's help
as well in maintaining a safe
quarterly environment
that allows New Yorkers to continue
their day-to-day lives with minimal
interruption
and it's always neither dangerous no
criminal Behavior will be tolerated with
that I'd like to introduce the mayor of
the city of New York mayor Adams thank
you thanks thanks so much Phil uh this
morning when the police commissioner and
I spoke on our morning briefing with the
other team uh we were clear that
tomorrow is a day that's going to draw a
great deal of attention to our city and
we know there are many questions around
the movement of the city and we want to
make sure that we sent a very clear and
Loud message uh as the deputy mayor
stated New York City is always always
ready uh we know that this is a city
where our NYPD and other law enforcement
entities must be prepared at any given
moment for anything to happen in this
city to start I want to make it clear
the commissioner stated over and over
again there has been no specific
specific credible threats to our city at
this time and all New Yorkers should go
on with their regular activities that
means going to work going to school
we're going to do our job as we always
do
if you usually Drive where State intake
public transportation it is easy to get
around on public transportation because
we expect some disruptions and
additional traffic there's a great deal
of additional traffic that may come in
the city and there will be street
closures near the courts and throughout
the city while there may be some rabble
Rouses
thinking about coming to our city
tomorrow a message is clear and simple
control yourselves
New York City is our home not a
playground for your misplaced anger
we have the safest large city in America
because we respect the rule of law in
New York City and although we have no
specific threats people like Marjorie
Taylor green who is known to spread
misinformation and hate speech she
stated she's coming to town while you're
in town be on your best behavior
as always we would not allow violence or
vandalism of any kind and if one is
caught participating in any act of
violence they will be arrested and held
accountable no matter who you are
and I want to again thank the police
department the commissioner of for their
response and for the necessary
preparation as we deal with this major
historical potential event that would
take place in the city this time I'd
like to introduce the police commission
of the city of New York
thank you Mr Mayor good afternoon
everyone thank you for being here
as always the NYPD is prepared to ensure
that everyone is able to have their
voices heard peacefully while exercising
their first amendment rights
we do this work in close collaboration
with our federal state and local
partners because keeping our city safe
is absolutely a collective effort
as the mayor stated there are no
credible or specific threats to New York
City at this time
New Yorkers may see an increased police
presence in parts of the city and should
anticipate intermittent road closures
over the next two days particularly in
Manhattan
to avoid delays I too urge everyone to
use mass transit when possible
as I said our job is to facilitate and
Safeguard the rights of people to
express themselves and those going about
their daily activities
but I will remind everyone that violence
and destruction are not part of
legitimate lawful expression and it will
never be tolerated in our city
but people we serve know this just as
they know that the NYPD will be out
there today tomorrow and every day to
make sure that they are safe thank you
Mr Mayor
sure
well we'll take some questions
so the permitting has happened is
actually uh done through City Hall but I
will say that anyone who protests is
expected to express themselves
peacefully and orderly
that incident is still under
investigation at this time
[Applause]
we value our relationship with our
partners and we're in constant
communication with them so if they do
see an influx of people or something out
of the ordinary they will contact us at
this time we don't see that happening
but we will have real-time information
if that does occur
[Applause]
[Music]
will that information be shared with the
public so they are going to be rolling
road closures I'm sure you can
understand based on the sensitivity of
it uh is going to be moving but we will
make sure we have enough offices to
facilitate transport throughout the city
um there is one area close to Trump
Tower that will have a road that is
closed just to a facilitate its
transport but beyond that they'll be
rolling road closures intermittently
through the city we're trying to have
minimal amount of intrusion into City
Life
[Applause]
we take uh any threats or concerns of
our elected officials and anyone in the
city very seriously so we have provided
some assistance in that regard and we
are investigating any threats that may
be made to the D.A or any of his uh his
staff
[Music]
as you know a number of laws were passed
uh when uh we went into having sensitive
zones and restricted zones It's actually
an e-felony to carry in some of those
zones even if you have a license some of
those zones include courthouses uh
Federal buildings and First Amendment
activities so we're not going to move
those I think responsible gun ownership
requires that you know what the laws are
where you are protesting and we expect
everyone to adhere to ours
well we'll come back to a police process
um how many
officers do you expect to be on the
streets also the Secret Service I mean
how have they come in and they simply
told you what to do or I mean how much
control are they having over security we
work with the Secret Service all the
time these are our partners uh I won't
go into how many numbers of police
officers will be on the street but we
will have enough to facilitate mobile
units if we need to respond to anything
but this is a collaborative effort with
our partners in secret service
[Music]
we have not needed to do that at this
time we have enough resources in place
but we can always call people into the
need occur
how many officers do you expect to be
deployed around the city uh just for
this specific detail and also are you
expecting or anticipating meeting
checkpoints for people on foot to get
into the courthouse area and to protest
outside of it well I won't get into
specific numbers of how many we will
deploy to that area if we need if we
find the need to Institute checkpoints
we will do so
yes um you mentioned both you and the
mayor about people taking public
transportation is there a plan to
increase police prevalence on public
transportation or what type of pool is
going in so as you know as we've talked
about since October we've surged a
number of officers into the transit
system so we expect to have a healthy uh
complement of officers in the transit
system tomorrow to facilitate travel
so you're a former police officers
Officer yourself I'm sure in the past
you were deployed to not the same
similar incidents now is Mayor what
concerns you the most
our security is concerned on the eve of
this arraignment well again as you
indicated a servant in the department I
really have a lack of concern I know how
well the New York City Police Department
is able to Pivot and shift based on the
circumstances that they are facing and
we are prepared the police commissioner
gave me a briefing she understands that
this is a unique situation and the New
York City Police Department is fully
prepared with the coordination of that
Deputy Mayor bank is doing with our
other law enforcement entities I have no
concern at all around this
oh politicians you mentioned Marjorie
Taylor green before the former
presidents stirring things up well you
know people stir stuff up all the time
but you know if you are prepared you
don't have to get prepared and we are
prepared and the ability to shift the
resources where they are needed I think
is extremely unique to this Police
Department we can manage several
different things at one time in this
department and that's what we're doing
the police commissioner laid out a full
plan with her executive team and she's
going to execute that plan based on the
niche
mayor what are you I'm over here what do
you think the spectacle of this next 24
hours the former president letting all
of his supporters know when he's wheels
up from Florida when he's Landing in
LaGuardia basically putting New York at
Center Stage once again as something of
an unprecedented spectacle from a legal
standpoint what do you make of all of
that I was I'm not in control of that
you know I view this entire moment that
we are in right now to one day be in the
Museum of the city of New York and I
think this is another uh chapter in this
experience and that this Administration
is going to show how we manage not only
National problems but Global problems as
well as the local problems and we'll be
prepared for whatever needs to be done
we built the team we got the right team
and New York is going to see once again
uh the professionalism that this Police
Commissioner has uh displayed and showed
to our troops
okay